what do you want baby got some granola
some cupcakes chips apples holding the
vending machines I know isn't it
something I can't decide what I want
[Music]
it's amazing it's so great thank you for
me I don't think he's in the ceiling
babe well like any of us really know all
right
is a pebble on that beach in Jamaica oh
go easy with the shaking oh my god
you like it yep I do make great
Christmas gifts but I couldn't make that
all right my time
oh um it's just I I didn't I didn't have
a lot of time so that's just a
placeholder right of course
The Adventures of Jimmy Halpert oh my
god this is awesome
that's my bike that's my desk and that
is my daughter
I mean
thank you for this amazing year thank
you for the food in front of us I mean
my family which is my number one
priority
much more than foams just took the call
Barba Corcoran
this better be an emergency there better
be a gun to your head
Charles Gina and I are in a hostage
situation oh god I shouldn't said the
gun thing
Terry regrets the way he answered the
phone weren't good ones there are
multiple gunmen they've blocked all the
exits they've taken the security guards
hostage and we're looking for a place to
hide it's awesome awesome awesome Lee
serious I am NOT enjoying this no matter
how much it is 100% my favorite movie
come to life
the important thing is keep Gena safe
you have a civilian with you I'm on the
way cool Oh also bring a pic of yourself
in a towel coming out of the shower
can't explain why okay gotta go bye
there's a serious situation going down
they need my help with did one of your
detectives lose his head of his own but
you don't even have a job Zeke you know
what I'm not supposed to be bringing
this up but I'm bringing it up I'm sick
of hearing you got things brewing you
ask me the only thing you got brewing is
a pot of BS kids I love you Sharon you
are perfect see get a job there's a
little hair on your shoulder well look
who's a silver fox well look at that I'm
sorry you're okay you don't feel like
your body's in decay or death is
inevitable my my somebody's being a
gloomy goose relax gloomy goose welcome
everybody to another gergich Christmas
Oh sadly one of our three beautiful
angels Millicent couldn't be here
tonight but our other two beauties
Miriam and Gladys are going to help
Gayle and me play a little tune
here we go a caroling up on the leaf so
green here we come the wandering so
better too busy love and joy come to you
and talk AB why does everyone act like
Jerry's the victim here he's the one
that didn't invite us to his Christmas
party Jerry filter Jerry filter who's
Jerry filter unsurprisingly Jerry scents
a lot of annoying emails so a while ago
I put a filter on all our accounts
everything from Jerry goes directly to
spam
and here's our imitation there's three
years of nice messages on here
congratulations on your wedding I'm
rooting for you kids Jerry hope you had
the best birthday Tom I just tied my
high scoring snake hey it's snowing oh
my god it's the first snowfall of
Christmas is that just so magical for
you little girl can you not wait to have
a hot chocolate and cuddle up with Papa
and tell him about all your Christmas
dreams
hmm it's not even a real snow like it's
dusting pitiful
hey Dwight Jim you cannot throw
snowballs in here Wow it's not a
snowball cause it's only a dusting right
look at that there's a pebble in there
you could have killed me oh don't be
such a baby
yeah who's a little girl now you
apologize to me right now there's
anything else you apologize right now no
very well then I challenge you to a
snowball fight on the first real snow of
winter yeah that sounds awesome can we
all do it no Andy it's a snowball fight
it's not fun go get your own thing beat
it
I'm sorry I had no idea no it's it's
okay okay oh my god okay this is it in
the end the greatest snowball isn't a
snowball at all it's fear Merry
Christmas thank you for joining me for
what promises to be the diggity Delphis
tree lighting in the history of the
nine-nine I don't understand where's the
tree it was inside us all along
brilliant Jake no Charles not everything
was inside of us all along the tree is
right here cool can we go now
obviously not behold the greatest
inflatable tree that murca has to offer
and now in the immortal words of st.
Nick turn on the compressor
hear that the sound of Christmas it's
deafening it's getting really big what's
I treated you get it's a jumbo they said
this ten meters tall that's roughly
thirty two point eight one eight someone
unplug it unplug it now can't it's one
of his old block
okay the tree has been contained wait we
left a man behind well
Terry's trapped in the break room
forever only thing we can do now is move
on with our lives is what Terry would
have wanted god bless us everyone
I can handcraft 17-foot canoes out of
western red cedar but I can't glue two
damn graham crackers together
look it's really easy I know a lot about
candy I'm playing with them I eat it
sometimes I play with it and eat it
[Music]
okay new plan
everyone else makes this candy house and
I make myself useful elsewhere
you